This is the only country along with
Greece that is cora now than before
having the euro as their official
currency to figures leave no space for
doubt.
Italians now have less purchasing power
than before they joined the euro,
which makes them one of the few
countries that became worse off after
joining the European.
Yeah.
We also looking about the second biggest
industrial power in all of Europe,
which is only surpassed by Germany.
In fact,
during the nineties,
the Italians were wealthier than the
British and the French.
Now,
if you're my age or older,
you might remember Ross Zazi,
Luciano Pavarotti,
or these so called Spaghetti Westerns.
Yes.
To view isn't.
He was one of the biggest powerhouses on
the planet and all the spine to their
governments and their ruling class.
The political history of Italy is our.
Should we say it well,
let's just say it makes game of thrones
looked like the gilmore girls.
Remember,
it's Allianz Se Sicilian,
Cosa Nostra,
the Kalibrasi Drain Gretta,
the Napoleon Komora,
and many,
many other gangs and yes,
all of them have important connections
with the highest levels of politicians,
but there's more than just a Nafisa
here.
During the Cold War,
some government officials held extreme
right wing terrorists.
Groups that organize the most violence
is acts that you could imagine,
and that's not even talking about the
extreme left wing,
which defines exactly stay quiet.
Either the Red Brigades kidnapped and
murdered an Italian pronunciation.
Look,
if you're into scary stories,
you should google something about the
propaganda duo more.
You can just watch the movie Il Divo
from Paolo Sorrentino.
You will discover a fascinating country
where politics,
anything was boring and now you might be
wondering,
well,
what exactly is going on in Italy today?
Do they have as much instability as they
did in the 19 seventies in the 19
eighties?
And he also was absolutely in just 10
years.
If at six different prime ministers 10
In other words,
keeping up with Italian politics is
pretty impossible mission and this is
why in this video we're not actually
going to talk about the Italian
elections that have been celebrated
recently,
not even about Berlusconi's and love
life.
Oh no,
because the real question here is how is
it possible that such a chaotic country
could manage to become quite so wealthy
and what is happening now?
Often two decades of economic
stagnation.
Today we're going to answer both of
those questions,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the good,
the bad,
and the ugly of Italian history.
Julio
and the reality is the good.
During the 1940 years,
the Italian Communist Party was the
biggest of its kind all across western
Europe with more than one point 3
million members.
They could win an election anytime they
want it.
As you can imagine,
the middle of the Cold War,
this was something America could not
happen.
So you remember the Marshall Plan?
Well,
if you've been following visual politics
for a long time,
you already know that Uncle Sam sent
lots and lots of money to Europe so they
can rebuild that destroyed city when it
came to you.
Isn't this money,
was not an immense to help the country,
but also to finance the only political
party you could face that communist
threat.
This policy was called Christian
democracy.
Mother's save your children from
Bolshevism vote Christian democracy in
the next 50 years.
It's an he had 30 different prime
ministers.
This means that the average span of an
Italian government was a little more
than a year and a half,
but they all had something in common.
Most of them,
they were Christian.
Democrat.
Governor within the Christian Democrats
is a man that you should know.
His name was Julio,
Andrea [inaudible],
and he became prime minister seven
different times and is the real
godfather of Christian democracy.
For years,
no Italian politician could do anything
without being.
Last Minute Mrs Andreotti
power wears out those who don't have it,
Julio and royalty.
But now the obvious question is,
well,
what did the Christian Democrats stand
for?
Well,
Christine Democracy was basically what
we call a catch up all party.
Anyone except communists could find his
or her place inside of this policy,
and this included deals with Napoleon
Kamora,
the Sicilian Cosa Nostra,
and allegedly extreme right wing groups
that terrorize the country during the 19
eighties,
but we're going to talk about all of
that in a future video.
The important thing here is that
Andreotti and his Christian Democrats
badly needed popular support and you
know,
you need to win some elections.
Did you do that?
What's better than employing people with
a good salary?
You see,
Italy has over three point $5 million
civil servants and they are among the
highest paid in the entire world.
This means a crazy public spending and
lots of bureaucracy and toxins.
Okay?
Reality is time until now,
easily is famous for two things.
Redstate and ineffective course,
a better understanding.
Let's imagine we have a company that
produces construction machines and we
have clients who doesn't pay US
naturally.
We would probably want to take him to
court
if we all in say France.
This process could take around two and a
half months,
but in the you could wait more than
three years before the problem gets
solved.
As you might imagine,
this is not exactly the best of business
planets,
but nevertheless,
I did say this sleep became one of the
wealthiest countries in all of Europe,
so how is that possible?
Well,
do you have.
You have the onset lies in the Italian
lira?
Yes.
You heard that right?
When they had their own currency,
the Italian central bank could evaluate
their currency anytime they needed to
put their economy on steroids.
When now you might be wondering,
well,
but Simon,
isn't that the worst thing that you
could do?
For instance,
in another video I told you that Germany
became rich partly because they have a
very stable currency,
the deutschmark and now it seems that
I'm telling you the exact opposite.
I mean,
how is it possible to digitally could
grapes so much having so much
corruption,
so much red tape,
and it's just constant evaluations.
Well,
let's dive in.
Freddy is the ugly,
having exited more than 1700 movies.
Rocco said Freddy.
Okay.
The Italian stallion dominated the adult
section of rental stores worldwide
during the 19 eighties,
and yes,
he is also an interesting symbol of the
Italian economy at that time,
a growth model that relied heavily on
inflation during the eighties and the
nineties.
It's elite flooded the world with cheap
products.
They were a kind of 20th century China.
As soon as something works in some other
country,
some Italian company would show up and
make the same thing,
but do it cheaper.
Let's have a look as an example.
American movies in America,
John Wayne Movies were incredibly
successful.
Let's go to Debbie,
so it was highly and movie producers
started doing more of the same,
but at the industrial level,
and this is how the Spaghetti Western
was at the same time,
the exact same thing was happening with
other industries.
Well,
Donna summer was making the entire
world.
Dan's Italian struck back with Sabrina
who did the same but cheaper and more
explicitly.
What about animated movies?
Walt Disney was launching a landon in
movie theaters.
The cheap Italian version was already
available in all of the countries.
Video stores.
That's innocently.
They were cheaply reproducing more than
just culture in general.
Italian companies mastered the art of
making cheap things,
or as economists would say,
low added value manufacturing isn't he
produced clothes,
furniture,
and plenty of plastic items.
If you bought an animated action figure
in the 19 nineties,
it probably has a made in Italy label
somewhere bus.
If you bought a stereo sound system,
it would have a made in Germany or made
in Japan label and now the question
arises,
well,
why was the Italian economy so strongly
based on selling cheap things abroad?
Well,
look at this chart,
you can see the value of the Italian
lira against the German mark.
As you can see,
during the eighties and nineties,
Italian currency was losing value all
the time.
In 1980 you could get 450 liras for one
German mark.
Fifteen years later you get a thousand
liras for one German mark.
So what does this mean?
It means innovation was way more
expensive for Italian companies than for
German ones.
For instance,
imagine we have an Italian production
company during the 19 eighties and we
want to a really innovative movie.
Something like star wars with state of
the art,
special effects and cutting edge
technology if we want to do that,
so we need to buy animation software
that's produced in Japan and special
cameras from America,
but since our Italian currency is losing
value all the time,
those things are more expensive for us
and to answer this that anytime we need
to hire someone new,
we're having to cut through never ending
red tape,
so suddenly not salmon is a good,
is it?
Yeah,
but now imagine that instead of making a
stall was like film.
We call our friend Rocco's Freddy and we
make an adult movie with him.
We just need a couple of cameras.
Remanned a bet,
and since we have a weak currency,
we can sell on movies abroad for a lower
price than any other film.
So simply following this model,
the Italian economy,
it grew sky high.
During these years,
thousands of smaller companies were
born,
but make no mistake here,
Italian smes have nothing to do with
German smes.
You see,
German middle stands had between 50 and
200 workers and they had enough scale to
invest money on research and innovation.
Italian companies were way smaller than
methods were more traditional and their
industries where well more in Italy
started taking account of its shadow
economy,
found that it made up a fifth of Italian
GDP.
As a result,
the economy grew by 18 percent
overnight,
so now you might wonder,
why should Italians innovate so much if
they were doing so well by not doing it
well.
Now I'm going to tell you why Silvio
Berlusconi is the ugly.
Now,
finally,
the 21st century,
Christine Democracy,
not really that important anymore.
Now the brand new leader of the center,
right wing is the man you see on screen
now and yes,
you might know that his name is Silvio
Berlusconi
little hair because my brain is so big,
it pushes everything else out.
Suvio Berlusconi thousands.
He was not the best year to the Italian
prime minister.
You know why?
Well,
because 2002 was the Italy abandons the
Italian lira and started using the euro.
And what's the main characteristic of
the euro?
Well,
no,
governments can decide by itself when
they devalue.
That's yours are issued by the European
Central Bank,
which includes representatives of all
the member countries.
This was a big problem for a country
like Italy,
which had become so addicted to
devaluation,
but things don't stop there.
Maybe you remember another thing that
happens at the beginning of the two
thousands.
And if you don't say,
well let me refresh your memory.
Joins the World Trade Organization at
last.
And so now you might be wondering,
well,
does China have to do with the Italian
economy?
Well,
as you might guess rather lot,
the fact that China had joined the World
Trade Organization was a symptom of
something much bigger as men's.
All of Asia was flooding the
international markets and it was not
only China.
Other countries like Thailand and
Bangladesh were already becoming
manufacturing powerhouses.
And surprise surprise.
What did these countries start
manufacturing first?
Well,
very,
very cheap things.
Same as the Italians buts even cheaper.
Thanks.
Then Germany was already off technology
wise.
So despite the Asian competition that
products,
they were still competitive.
Meanwhile isn't he could not go back to
old school devaluation first,
they were now part of the euro and
second devaluing wasn't a solution
against Asia's cheap salaries.
Here's an example.
One of the most symbolic Italian
companies is Fiat.
In 1998,
they sold over one point $3 million cars
in your.
Now they only sell 700,000
and they can't get into new markets.
Other brands like BMW still maintain
their share on their traditional markets
and also they're growing and emerging
countries like China,
but just,
Oh,
hold on a minute here because we're not
done yet.
You really know how it's has over 3
million civil servants.
Well,
they all still there and they still have
to be paid.
In other words,
while the Italian economy is falling and
the government is collecting fewer and
fewer taxes,
they all still spending the same amount
of money.
So what?
What does that mean?
It means essentially is now the fourth
most indebted country on the planet.
They're public debt is over 130 percent
of their GDP,
and this certificate is simply crazy.
Is Europe's next big?
So now the question is,
should Italy abandon the euro so that
they can go back to that devaluation
methods and cheap manufacturing?
Maybe they should follow the German
model and let their companies innovate
more while I've said my piece.
So I'll just leave it to you to leave
your comments in the section below.
And if you are wondering now about how
the German economic model works,
maybe you missed our previous video,
just click on this one.
You can see on the screen now and you'll
learn everything you need to know about
Germany's economy.
There you go.
And also don't forget to visit the
reconsidered media podcasts.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that aren't mine,
and as always,
don't forget,
we publish new videos every Monday and
every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button and you
will not miss a single post.
If you liked this video,
give it a thumbs up.
As always,
see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my love,
of course you can join us at reconsider
media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast.